de a de a de y a deux mondes voilà il y
a deux idées ou bien vous tirez sur la
cible ou bien vous tirez sur ma
gueule pour ceux qui peuvent pas me
blirer allez-y ça compte aussi je vous
dis c'est très simple une flèche chacun
ok à chaque fois le dernier celui qui
fait le moins de points est éliminé tac
tac tac tac tac pour la première étant
donné que nous sommes 10 et que je veux
pas que le jeu dure jusqu'à 21h surtout
qu'il y en a des invités qui arrivent
patri Sébastien il y a Miss France il y
a geoffroid le jeune il y a Patrick
leeveux tu
sors
s alors bonne calvous s vous PLT elle é
bonneas dit qu'elle était bonne tu
sors on veut pas deur ici alors les chér
c'est très simple je vous dis la vérité
ce qu'on va faire c'est que vous allez
jouer tous ensemble et vous allez jouer
les chroniqueurs contre ma personne ok
d'AC si vous gagnez franchement je vous
le jure que c'est vrai je vous offrirai
sur le prime et je ne charie pas du tout
savez quand je premz un cadeau je vous
ferai un beau cadeau cade un beau cadeau
de Noël en revanche si vous perdez c'est
vous qui devez faire un cadeau chacun
demain mais c'était prévu déjà mais un
vrai j'en ai Mar des cadeaux pouris là
gen des ép l'ôel m'offrait des épées des
trucsen fout tu faire d' épé je veux des
vrais cadeaux vous savez comment je
m'habille vous savez quel est Mony et
ben vous allez faire l'avenue Montaigne
et vous
revenez
[Applaudissements]
pas
compliqué pas le temps pas compliqué les
gars rien à cé des puces
[Applaudissements]
é pas
mal la pêche
tu dismoi tu tu vas traverser des
marages
ouo allez on y va les chér alors je vous
explique vous allez je vais d'abord je
bien les règles alors déjà on on me vous
voir bien les règles ça va hein je les
note les règles allez notles sur ton cul
plutôt merci oh ça va c'est comme ma
sœur c'est comme ma sœur l' l'utre à
côté alors y a la juge des novas les
C est-ce que vous voulez qu'avant on
fasse le concours de fléchettes pour le
petit kiif on se revoit euh le F rire
qu'on a eu hier ah ah ou je p qu'on
revoit plusieurs fois dans cette
émission est-ce qu'il est prêt CIT
horrible il sera prêt à 19h10 d'accord
donc là on est d'accord qu' je aux
fléchettes tu as rienable mais en fait
tu sers à
quoi bonne question bravo très bien
merci non c'est un ex employé euh allez
on y va donc les chérriis c'est très
simple vous êtes neuf au départ d'abord
je vais en éliminer trois les trois
derniers ouais ensuite vous serez plus
que 6 6 2 4 les quatre derniers
demi-finales de 4 2 2 un gagnant un
gagnant qui m'affronte okair OK et le
gagnant gagne le gagnant gagne je
rappelle que le gagnant gagne le père d'
père attention je démarre comme ça je
vous je vous donnerai votre fléchette à
chaque fois c'est à toi de démarrer tu
te mets là et tu fermes ta gueule merci
non tu mors tu veux tu sois derrière le
rouge voilà
[Applaudissements]
allez les mecs ça va il a fait 6 DISM on
dirait qu'il a
fait il a fait 6 c'est une catastrophe à
to fait le 6 blanc il a fait le ah faut
regarder les num tu vas pas tarder oui
il faut regarder non mais en fait
essayer juste de la mettre normalement
voilà faut juste essayer de la
mettre pas
mal le cadeau le cadeau changement de
règle je vais en éliminer quatre ah
ouais non parce qu'en fait ça va être
trop long sinon donc attention quatre
éliminés mordu tu te mors tu mors 11 11
ça va
[Applaudissements]
c'estux pas ah oui je allez kéké rouge
ou noir
no non pour tu veux je vous jure que la
rouge est M croyez-moi non mais je crois
c le rouge gagne toujours donnez-moi la
noire voir et après vas-y on parle je
vais jouer avec la rouge après mais je
vais vous montrer ce qui va gagner VO al
je prends la rouge
voilà ou pas ou pas si elle rate elle va
me défoncer ouais euh ok la noir allez
[Musique]
k alors si je peux donner un conseil
joue avec la rouge non mais vous avez
trafiqué les trucs vous avez trafiqué
les trucs ah non c'est ma peau je viens
Decher la PE avec alors
att tu t'es fait mal non non c'est rien
ouis je me suis planté la main mais
c'est pas grave ça va ouais ça saigne
mais ça va ça va j ça saigne non mais
attends c'est une BAR
attendezentre toi
K c'est
bon quand
même Kell 15 pour l'instant alors pour
l'instant on a 20 11 je laisse les deux
derniers pour l'instant benim et Kelly
sont a priori qualifié d'accord
Jean-Michel et cardos pour l'instant
c'est pas bon tu veux la rouge ou la
noire la noire la rouge t' la
rouge comm les tirag au sort tu sais pas
pas plus un petit pansement à
Kell pansement pour Kell
[Applaudissements]
10 pour l'instant Verdez pas c'est pas
bon je rappelle qu'il a qure éliminés si
vous PZ vous un peu le cul parce que non
mais toi on dirait tu porte de la
chapelle sur la tête de ma mère les gars
je v vous dire je vais faire si éliminés
ah ouais il en restera trois qui vont
vont s'affronter rent même allez allez
vas-y allez vas-yi le
cul tu crois pas tu y crois mais
ouais par déjà Daniel normalement j'ai
paré sur toi en final contre moi non non
mais tu veux pas t'avancer là-bas
aussi tu ti
com fait qu non non non 18 18 x 2 les
chéris tr non non non non 18 x 3 x mich
SMI mich SMI m
sm
x 54 alors par contre par contre Al al
mir mir à de votre ami s'il s'approche
encore comme ça une fois il est
dimin c'est bon vas-y j'ai non mais tu
es folle com ça fait rien j'ai
rienus Ahoua non non là c'est mort là
c'est
Morty on va don le cade on va le cadeau
attendez attendez attendez attends
attends attend pour l'instant les les
trois qualifiés sont mundirou merci
Benaim et Kelly ok ça va être dur pour
vous hein moi ça va être dur pour vous
mais après ils vont faire un truc après
le gag le niveau est très élevé ouis ça
va être dur pour moi c'est ce qu'on
disait aussi au
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bac c'est très drôle c'est très
drôleô je vais
[Applaudissements]
demander je vais demander je vais
demander au trois finalistes de bien
vouloir venir me rejoindre Kelly Ben et
dans l'ordre donc c'est ben qui en
premierite rouge ou no je m'en fiche
r tu
veux
tu mais tu pas je t'avance un peu trop
j'aime pas ça vasy
domtion att je crois qu'elle fait 18 par
deur vousz juste planter norm numéro
voulezoulez attentionut prier faut bien
jouer par pour
toeze la M vous mez non pas du
toutz c'est bon vas-y maman mais arrête
deappeler maman toi connard
connard es
Conz mettezvous là pour l'instant pour
l'instant vous êtes
finalist ça va jouer si fa moins de 16
et si tu je t'explique c'est pas comme
ça non mais c'est le C en arrière c'est
pas le cul en avant c'est bon là ok
estce que là c'est bon reste bien comme
ça reste bien comme ça tu peux av es
loin là
oh
18 4 4 18 18 c'est donc la finale mundir
à moi Kelly je suis désolé
Kelly tris flèches flch trois fléchettes
je t'explique le perdant doit faire un
cadeau à l'autre un cadeau à l'autre sur
trois fléchettes on fait le calcul
tu commence bah non c'est à toi de
commencer c'est toi le challenger ok
ah non mais on a fait une chacun une
chacun s pas mal
oh le prier cadeau end le
cadeau c'est dans le verre c'est 25 25
25 c'est 25 dans le vert non mais je te
le dis 25 c'est bien 25 ouais 5 ça y
est 7 comment tu as fait pour la planter
ouais c'est ouf non mais ça ve rien dire
non tu t'avances trop j'eni rien à
[__] tu V
arrêter j'ai rien à
[__]
Z j'ai 255 25 c'est éliminatoire j'ai 25
Mo je suis bien gentil de te laisser 25
je suis bien gentil de te laisser e toi
attends le C en arrière on a dit ok
je suis à 16 he ou 9 et 9
16 non tu t'avances beaucoup trop sans
char c'est
insupportablep mais c'est non mais frère
mets-toi là 17 non 17 et 25 17 17
[Applaudissements]
1 le cadeau le cadeau le cadeau le
cadeau le cadeau le cadeau
voilà
cadeau mon fils e mon fils en au un sur
le bon coin ce weekend 20 balles faites
gaffe profitez-en parce qu'il va tous
les prendre là bon comment j'ai fait moi
donc je suis à combien donc moi non moi
j'étais donc à 16 + 22 non quoi 16 + 2
16 16 combien moi c'est écrit sur
tableau là regarde au tableau regardez
regardez là 16 7 et 9 7 + 9 il fait 17 +
non bravo
voilà tuag quand même on gagne quand
même7+
29 Com Com il a 7 + 9 et moi j'ai 25 +
17 ça veut dire donc 16 donc
16 moi je suis à 16 et toi tu es à
combien tu 42 16 et 42 donc il faut que
je fasse fa que tu fasses 100 mais non
pour gagner faut que je fasse 30 à peu
près à 30 je gagne 30 com FO 3 non non
non Tuan pas Esser tu V essayer de viser
le vin si tu nous offres un cadeau
bénisse B te bénisse le cadeau où je
t'emmène oh
[Applaudissements]
[__] mais ça vous fait quoi
vous avez jamais perdu de votre vie
c'est un truc de fouentend
MO
loser sa pourquoi vous savez pourquoi
j'ai perdu pourquoi parce que je m'étais
pas entraîné avant lui il s'est entraîné
ah si parceil a fait des
qualifications pas chaud ah oui j'était
pas chaud faire la
belle je te fais un kit double sur une
fléchette en de
oui
pas
c'est trop près d'ici il faut prendre
des risques
faut quoi tuas une noir quoi alors je
prends une noire mets-toi par là là je
mettre avec toi Metsi la
B connaisse prends une rouge comme ça
chacun voit le laisser les traces non
non je prends la no rou c'est de la
merde prends une rouge comme ça chacun
la prends une rouge les ENL les
autresouè toutes les
autilà qui est passé par là j'ai des
traces
j'ai V des traces de pas remettezles
j'aime bien remettez les traces de
pain ah ouais attends pourquoi c'est moi
qui
commence
Cau un trou du cul to ça n'existe
pas pas mais c'est feuille ciseau c'est
quoi ça c'est le pu non le pu g de fois
ça
comptete ciseau on pierre feuille C
ciseau voilà je t'enveloppe je
t'enveloppe avec cillou pas du tout le
caillot déchire la feuille il f mec il
son F
me caillou mec vous avez déjà vu une
feuille comm caillou le caillou le
caillou prends donne-moi une feuille
donne-moi une feuille B je vais vous
montrer tu veux direa regarde le caillou
déchire la feuille est-ce que la feuille
peut déchirer le caillou regardez par
contre la feuille regardez voilà
regardez et le caillou regardez et le
caillou revient voilà voilà que le
magicien allez terminé
com qu' qu'estce que j'ai fait allez
vas-y allez vas-y tu commence à me faire
[Rires]
chier si toi PL pas tu as perdu comment
çaasoaner mais'estce tu es f ou
quoi
[Musique]
faner
pasâ
cade
detéeur
toou pasou pas bien plus
ha
[Applaudissements]
VO ça va E les gars il a fait trois on
dirait qu'il a fait 40 mais au moins il
a au moins
quoi les gars je vais vous dire et on
est tous d'accord quoi il y a qu'une
seule unique fléchette qui va compter ce
soir c'est
[Rires]
celle-ci ça va marcher ça va marcher il
[Applaudissements]
a
ou ou
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça elle est trué
oh du canure s'il vous plaît on arrête
tout c'est normal ça c'est une Bou non
il y a un problème alors je vais vous
dire c'est pas une fléchette c'est pas
une fléchette réglement pas je
dis je te dis je croyais pas ça de ta
part vraiment non mais je te dis je suis
extrêmement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
déçu